MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to Special Relativity, 8.20.
In this section, we're going
to talk about proper velocity.
We have seen already concepts
of proper time and proper length
as the time and
the space as seen
in the object's own
reference frame.
So now we want to try to
find something similar
for velocities, as we
have seen the Lorentz
transformation
applied to velocities
of a quite difficult form.
As a reminder, velocity
is given as a change
in space of a change in time.
We have seen the Lorentz
transformation of a velocity x
in a reference frame which is
boosted in the same direction
x.
And you see that this
new velocity x prime
is given by new x
minus v. So there's
a velocity addition
going on, which
is corrected then by this factor
1 minus uxv over c squared.
You've also seen that even so,
the boost is in x direction.
There's also modification of
the velocity in y direction
and in z direction.
OK?
So you see that
basically, there is this--
the velocity itself is
corrected with this new factor.
Note here that there
is a special case
in which the direct-- the
velocity in x direction
is equal to 0.
Think about this object
being in its own rest frame,
again, where the velocity
in the booth direction is 0.
You see that both
equations simplify
for ux prime that would be
simply equal to minus v,
where uy prime would be uy
prime and uv prime would be uv.
So let's try to get at it.
Let's try to express velocities
in terms of the proper time,
at the time as it ticks in
the object reference frame.
So we have seen that the
time is given by gamma times
the time in the rest frame
or time in the proper--
times gamma times
the proper time.
Note here that we have
two different gamma
factors to play with.
One is a gamma factor of
the Lorentz transformation.
And this gamma here
is the gamma using
the speed of the object in
a specific reference frame.
So this is the gamma which
is a gamma factor which
is a gamma of v of the velocity
or the speed of the object.
And now we can just simply
define proper velocity
if I use this vector eta here,
which is a four vector, which
is the derivative of the spatial
component with the proper time.
And when we do this, you find
this relatively simple solution
of gamma times c for the 0's
component, gamma times ux,
gamma times uy, and gamma times
uz for the last component.
So the question now is, we
defined this new velocity
of an object where
the time of the object
ticks in its own
reference frame using
this property as proper time.
OK?
If we now try a Lorentz
transformation on this,
we can simply apply the matrix
for Lorentz transformation
on this four vector and
find the solution here.
You can see that this
is consistent by doing
this with the original
components in this proper time
as well.
You see that those actually
are a consistent answer.
It makes a lot of sense.